due to hey guys Ryan right here so it's
a very special video today another
unboxing video and I have brought with
me today salamander salad my co-host for
1up box 1up box in case you guys don't
know it's kind of like loot crate except
it's with nintendo themed stuff i never
find out the theme in advance because I
like to be surprised and guess with the
famous all right Sally what I would like
for you to do is be the hot woman that
presents this one at a time from
smallest to largest
just feel around you know the difference
okay
and that smells there's an actual scent
in the room Wow just grab an item I
don't want to see it Captain America oh
my god it's a full on Captain America
bobblehead holy [ __ ] oh yeah every time
I see one of these I have always got to
get it like well not always got to get
it I always want to get it oh [ __ ] yeah
holy crabs legit bobblehead and I got a
perfect spot in my home for it next line
I'm Sally it's comic book normal theme
this month it's an air freshener it's a
spider-man air freshener I had no idea
what the theme was this one is so far my
favorite one
Nintendo peeps what is this this is a
patch oh you're a one up boxes just got
a bunch of different here I wasn't
Batman that man in there you know I
can't get enough Batman toys I have a
specific section in my home that I'm
looking at right now that is dedicated
to like Batman pretty much never grow up
never surrender oh yeah you know it says
here owed you so the month is here oh
okay cool
holy [ __ ] where are my keys this is
gonna go perfect with my 1up box Harley
Quinn little keychain ear oh the shirt
there's a shirt that's right there's a
shirt no I just forgot it like just
thinking about the theme this no it is a
bobble it says right there do I know
bobble him
you know what you should pay attention
next time I'll try not to freak out oh
my god oh my god I'm so jealous
Wow and it's so cool what you could see
my nipple you could see my nipple of
excitement you guys know when I get
excited my nipples get hard dude it's
all like Batman stuff first off I just
realized what this pin isn't that's
awesome no there's so much cool [ __ ]
right now
okay this one I bought is basically it's
the Batman signal light but there's a
toad instead and and oh [ __ ]
Alyssa and Dan are gonna be so jealous
no [ __ ] losers this [ __ ] is so much
more worth than 12 bucks
I never wear necklaces but today I am
Thank You 1up box holy [ __ ] this stuff
is so cool yeah I'm gonna keep the bag
actually yes okay so the bobblehead air
freshener
Batman patch keyring oh sure
necklace of the triangle from Zelda and
a pin you know every time I do it up
because unboxing videos require no work
than just me because any time I do it
I'm like whatever people
like these so I'm gonna do it for them
but then as the video goes I'm like I
totally forgot how awesome this boxes Oh
a surrogate how cool this boxes anyway
guys yeah I put a link in the
description box if you guys want to buy
a 1up box as well go there purchase one
so that way you could be just like the
great Ryan Wright anyway guys thank you
so much thank you Sally for being here
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects Sally has
a channel to the Salamanders Sally check
it out
and you can follow us both on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where Sally is
constantly posting pictures of her left
nipple significantly bigger those
pictures of you and your bra no I said
like wearing a bra while wearing a shirt
then technically yeah like my left
nipple is present right now but you
can't see it it's not visible yeah on
her Instagram she post know your folders
do you want to get followers I want to
get respect respect love [ __ ] cares
about respect
so I wanted to give a quick shout out to
two people that I know of here in
California Stacy and Ashley they have an
artwork company called us artworks
basically they do a lot of different
designs but it's mainly Nintendo based
stuff it's really cool designs really
cool pictures and they even do
customized pictures as well and if you
guys love Nintendo seriously if you just
want to like look at a cool picture
every once in a while or if you want to
buy something you go to facebook.com
slash us artworks check it out they have
an Instagram as well seriously some of
the coolest photos I've ever seen I'm
gonna be buying [ __ ] off of them you can
buy stuff off of them too you just got
some of the message but seriously it's
really worth it they do customized
paintings so I'm gonna get a customized
picture of me with my schlong connected
to my mouth I want to be like the human
centipede but I'm connected to my penis
from the mouth I do talk about sex an
awful lot do that